would you rather have someone say and
they're serious when they say this they
cut you off by going
quiet
or shut
up
or which bothers me
or a snap what's the first one what's
what's the one thing I have mine that
I'd be like okay I'm okay with that
which one am I okay with well out of all
of them what's the what's the worst and
what's the one that snap is the worst
Snap Store hey send a chill up my spine
sh I can I guess deal with SH is okay
but you know what mine is I don't mind
when someone says shut up quiet you
don't mind it it's kind of just funny
because I say it to people too I go
people would be talking when I'm walking
by or driving I go quiet and I go huh
what are he say I always say it I always
say quiet